5 Uhr morgens die Sonne geht auf über
der Wüste kowalz der National Camel
Racing Club hat zum Rennen geladen es
sind die Vorentscheidungen für die
großen Wettkämpfe im Winter die Strecke
8 km lang die Tiere aus dem ganzen Land
wertvolle Züchtungen hier geht es um
Millionen und es wird gewettet wie beim
Pferdesport
wie funktioniert es
ich nehme die Nummer die implantiert ist
am Nacken des Kamels auf eine Mikrowelle
ich trage
[Musik]
und dann das nächste Tier der da zum
Beispiel ist die Nummer 16
ist heute mit seinen Jungtieren gekommen
der kamelzüchter will die Tiere testen
sie sollen sich an die Rennen gewöhnen
auf ihren Rücken keine Menschen sondern
Roboter vor einigen Jahren wurden die
Kinder Jockeys verboten und durch kleine
Roboter ersetzt voll ausgestattet mit
Funkgerät und Peitsche
was brauchen die Tiere nicht besonderes
man muss aufs Futter achten dass
Training die Ernährung man muss halt auf
die Tiere aufpassen auf ihren
allgemeinen Zustand so als ob man sich
um einen seiner eigenen Söhne kümmert
gerade bei den Rennen
als Kind ist er schimmery selbst
geritten heute dirigiert er die Roboter
aus seinem Auto ich darf beim Start mit
dabei sein
es geht los
mit 80 Sachen fährt vorbei nebenher und
die regiert die Kamele übers Funkgerät
seine Tiere laufen im Mittelfeld immer
wieder spricht er sie an doch für die
vorderen Plätze sieht es heute schlecht
aus
Kuwait ist ein reiches Land reichenöl
reichen Sonne die Menschen Zahlen kaum
Steuern es gibt keinen Alkohol und viele
Frauen sind verschleiert
wir fahren nach solebia die Stadt der
trostlosen hier leben die Beton rund
120.000 Menschen ohne Pass ohne Rechte
als Kuwait in den 1960er Jahren
unabhängig wurde ordnete der Emir an
dass sich alle Menschen innerhalb von
zwei Jahren registrieren lassen sollen
viele haben diese Frist für säumt aus
Unkenntnis oder Mangel der Bildung so
wurden sie zu starten losen
ja was wir hier zeigen was wir hier
sehen das ist der Regierung von Kuwait
nicht genehm wenn einem der reichsten
Länder der Welt leben tausende
zehntausende Menschen im weltlich Hütten
sie kämpfen darum überhaupt schon eine
Miete zu zahlen überhaupt ein Stück Land
zu bekommen das dürfen sie eigentlich
nicht und sind immer eigentlich von der
Obdachlosigkeit bedroht
ich bin verabredet mit Buschstraße
aber verheiratet mit einem Staatenlosen
Busra hatte sich dieses Jahr für die
Wahlen aufgestellt sie will für die
Rechte der rechtlosen kämpfen damit sie
Papiere bekommen damit sie reisen
arbeiten wählen können
Sie uns kurz erklären wie ihre Kinder
und Enkelkinder leben
meine Kinder haben keine Arbeit es gibt
keine Arbeit für sie und noch etwas die
Söhne kowaitischer frauen dürfen zwar
nun auch bei der Polizei und Armee
dienen aber auch dort gibt es
Diskriminierung
[Musik]
erzählt uns noch wie schwierig es ist
für Staatenlose eine Wohnung zu mieten
oder Eigentum zu besitzen
sie selbst hat nur zwölf Stimme erhalten
bei den Wahlen im Parlament sagt sie
werde die Situation der Staatenlosen
selten angesprochen sondern einfach
ignoriert
[Musik]
immer wieder kommt es zu Aufständen die
Demonstranten werden oft verhaftet
Proteste sollen im Keim erstickt werden
warum ist das Problem der wie du noch
immer nicht gelöst warum gibt es so viel
Armut und Ungerechtigkeit in einem
reichen Land
für diese Fragen bin ich verabredet mit
der Menschenrechtlerin
haben dieselben Wurzeln sie sprechen
dieselbe Sprache haben dieselbe Religion
dieselben Traditionen denselben
Hintergrund
trotzdem gibt es immer noch alte
archaische und wissenschaftliche falsche
Ideen in der Gesellschaft und diese
bestimmen immer noch wer eine
Staatsbürgerschaft verdient und wer
nicht
wie steht es um die Menschenrechte hier
im Vergleich zu den anderen Golfstaaten
ist demokratischer im Vergleich zu
anderen Golfstaaten
hier werden fast alle Themen
angesprochen aber man trifft hier immer
wieder auf rote Linien
und hier herrscht ein Art Krankheit die
typisch ist für den Mittleren Osten man
verleugnet Probleme
ein modernes Kuwait in dem die Rechte
der Minderheiten geschützt sind ist wohl
noch ein weiter Weg ein erster Schritt
nach den Wahlen sind erstmals zwei
Frauen ins Parlament eingezogen
zurück zuvor warse schimmeri und seinen
Kamelen
sind Sie mit dem Ergebnis zufrieden
hallo ob ich mit dem Ergebnis zufrieden
bin nein warum
weil ich es gewohnt bin den ersten Platz
zu bekommen
nicht den fünften oder sechsten Platz
wie heute
warum sind eigentlich hier keine Frauen
im Rennen vertreten
schauen sie so ein Rennen ist hart und
Frauen können solche Härten nicht
ertragen
sie können nicht in der Sonne stehen nur
ein wenig
können sie das aushalten sie können es
nicht stimmt männer sind da den Frauen
überlegen verstehen Sie
traditionelle Rollenmuster selbst beim
Kamelrennen in Kuwait ist es Rennen
zwischen Tradition und Moderne noch
nicht entschieden
[Musik]